this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 71 sitting here with EC Echo
Charles Trust
yeah so trust obviously is the the the
foundation of relationships and not just
personal relationships with business
relationships people that you interact
with your family the whole nine yards so
what happens when trust gets broken
what do you do
and really that can happen from two
directions one is you broke the trust
the other was someone else broke the
trust
so I think first and foremost it's very
important to understand the impact of
broken trust because
what we're going to talk about is that
it is very very very difficult to
rebuild and get I mean this is like if
someone breaks let's say you have a
friend that that breaks your trust
it could take
first of all there's a chance that it
could never recover yeah I mean
depending on what it is there's a chance
you could never recover
if it is a recoverable item that was
broken
like they did something a little bit
less negatively impacting your life
it could still take years
so what I'm saying is nothing's more
important in a relationship between two
human beings than making sure that you
don't break trust don't lie this is the
lesson that you teach your kid right
your kid does something stupid
hey you punish him for doing something
stupid your kid does something stupid
and lies about it it's next level right
that's when that's when it's going to
get kind of wild they're going to make
sure they don't forget that
so to keep that in mind
in any time you're interacting with
people that trust and integrity is most
important than you got
if you break it
and look if you make a mistake and break
it that's totally it's it's not totally
different because you can make a mistake
and break someone's trust and now
they're like you know but you you are
already on the are on the path to
rebuild because you explain hey you take
ownership this is a mistake
but if you break someone else's trust
first of all you got to recognize that
it's a problem and you've gotta you've
got to recognize that there's a decent
chance that no one should ever trust you
again
[Laughter]
which is which is by the way a class of
humans
there's a class of human beings trust is
not a thing for them they don't care
like they're they're gonna
they're gonna they don't care about it
like everything I just said they're kind
of struggling their shoulders like what
are you talking about like hey I gotta
get mine and hey you know what I mean
hey you gotta take care of yourself and
you got to take care of number one and
you know if they don't want to trust me
that's fine I still got my you know what
I mean that there's a whole class of
human beings that are like that so stay
away from them for sure but if you're
not like that and you accidentally or
you purposely broke someone's trust and
now you're trying to rebuild it
I'm just gonna say right out of the gate
don't expect some kind of forgiveness
don't expect oh I'm really sorry I
shouldn't have done that don't expect
that that things are handled now because
they're actually not
don't expect them to trust you don't
expect you to do what you you don't
trust me anymore no I don't actually
trust you anymore and they might not
they may or may not say that to you yeah
but you have a lot of work to do
and the way that you're going to do it
is by
performing and being trustworthy for a
long long long time
and hopefully over time you can rebuild
you may never get back to like a 100
trust you may never clear that that
blemish off your record you know you're
like a felon it's just on there and
that's the way it is going to show up on
your police report
so you gotta expect that
that's what you got to expect now on the
other side how to rebuild
if someone else broke it right and again
first of all you got to recognize this
problem second of all you got to
recognize that there's a you probably
shouldn't ever trust them again right
like they made they made now listen like
I said if they made a mistake we're in a
kind of a different category than
someone that consciously decides oh I'm
gonna
I I think I can get away with this or
I'm gonna make this move because it's
better for me
someone breaks your trust look I'm not
saying you can't work with them anymore
and I mean I had to work with people
that I didn't really trust 100 but okay
now what I do watch them right don't
give them
impactful things that you don't have
trust in them on
and then I mean I think you just start
small
and you start giving a little bit of
trust back and hopefully you can grow
that over time if they're repentant in
their behavior if they are
trying to rebuild that trust if they're
taking ownership of their mistakes then
I think you can move it in the right
direction
but
like I said you got to use caution with
this type of person because they might
be a snake right like just a just a rat
just a snake and so like a dog with kids
like you really you really like your dog
but you still shouldn't leave your dog
in a room like alone with a toddler you
know because that's not just not a good
thing to do because a dog is still a dog
and a rat is still a rat and a snake is
still a snake so you give them that
opportunity
and they're probably gonna break your
trust
so that's what I'm saying I think the
the point here is
trust is
like a
a such a valuable thing and you better
treat it that way
um
there you go oh you're taking notes over
here what's up it's kind of like Teeth
enamel right once you lose it it's gone
one of those kind of things super hard
you know I don't know I just thought of
that butt um no you said a mistake like
if someone makes a mistake right like
what like what would be an example of
like a mistake and wait wait let me be
sure that I yeah I understand or say you
make a mistake then it's like easier to
be like okay it was just a mistake and
maybe like gain have trust me right
right yeah like we'll be in just a
mistake would be like oh you know you
had our equipment in your car you left
the car open this stuff got stolen all
right and so you yeah you're trusting me
to over yeah yeah yeah that's like a
different kind of trust right yeah so
you know some people they'll say it was
a lapse of judgment okay and they'll
kind of almost try to categorize that as
just a mistake you know like
I don't know like what's the the deal
like I don't know if you get with
someone's girlfriend or something like
that you know like oh I had a lapse of
judgment kind of a thing
where it's like that's not like an
innocent mistake like the one you're
saying no it's totally different that's
like violating trust right like that
kind of whatever
um but they say lapse of judgment
you give that any
cred it's a step yeah you know but it
also could be an excuse I might sound
like an excuse and it might be an excuse
when I hear it yeah like what what would
be in an innocent Not Innocent but like
a legitimate just lapse of judgment that
wouldn't have the weight of an actual
betrayal see what I'm saying like a
lapse of judgment that's like legit
um
a lapse of judgment oh I know like maybe
if someone like had like a meeting or
something like let's say me and you had
a meeting with somebody I don't know
that was kind of we're gonna do
something cool or big and I went out
drinking the night before because I was
maybe fired up and I drank too much
and then I came to the meeting like
super hungover yeah like that
that could be a lobster I think an
example similar to that but maybe a
little bit more like
legit is
there's a big business opportunity and a
guy like reaches out to you and me and I
don't see the email and you go and meet
with the guy and I'm like dude you
didn't even tell me about this big
business opportunity you see what I'm
saying yeah yeah and you're like oh man
I I saw your email I thought you just
didn't care about it you know what I
mean so then it's like okay we were just
a little not aligned on what was
important what's not you made a judgment
call I don't agree with your judgment
okay you know there's like
combat scenarios where people people do
things and and it's sort of a bad
judgment you know we actually have a
saying for it's a good initiative bad
judgment yeah like hey I thought I would
just be smart for me to just storm you
know get across the street and take that
other house down yeah it's like bro no
one knew you were going there yeah yeah
you know what I mean so things like that
happen that's bad judgment and that
would impact trust because obviously
you're doing stuff that you shouldn't be
doing now is it on me yeah it's on me
because if I'm the leader and I didn't
explain to you hey don't clear any other
buildings that aren't part of the target
set you go do it anyways
so
we got some we got some issues I'm
thinking of this scenario it doesn't
have to do with storming buildings by
the way so I was in Kong Kwai a few
weeks ago whatever
and Terry big sexy who's there happened
to be there him in the ring so but they
were leaving like a two days after we
arrived there so we only had essentially
one day to like
catch up or whatever
um so I was like oh let's go up to my
younger brother's house right and so I'm
on the phone with my bro my younger
brother and
Terry so basically something came up
where it's like oh man the time is
running out you know we got kids now
they're going to bed so it's like we
don't really have time to go up to
yata's house because he lives in color
which is like a good 20 minutes like
drive one way
but Terry literally is he's staying
walking distance from me and there's a
bar that's walking distance from us like
it's in the same kind of area so I was
like ah we only got basically like an
hour left for me to
I don't know to to hang for whatever oh
yeah because the bar is going to close
so
me thinking I thought this literally for
like 10 seconds where I'm like oh I'll
call you out because the plan was like
oh yeah all three of us are going to
hang out for Terry's last day so maybe
go up to yatza's house or something like
this but time got away from us it would
have been just the circumstances turned
out where going up to yata's house is
like unrealistic We're not gonna do that
so we're like oh we'll just go to this
bar real quick we'll hang out have you
know have a few laughs whatever I look
we only have an hour left so I mean
Terry can just shoot up there if I tell
my younger brother oh we're going to
this bar he's gonna say no because by
the time he even gets there put on his
clothes that's at least five minutes by
the time he gets there he's gonna be
like freaking there's just a few minutes
left you know so he's not gonna come all
the way down to this side so anyway I
thought that for like 10 seconds didn't
tell him so I was like ah let's just go
yeah you know yacht is caught up for the
night you know he's with his kids and
all this stuff they have school the next
day all this stuff right
so me and Terry go have a few laughs or
whatever come to find out like you have
to Woulda wanted to go it wasn't a big
deal or nothing like that but I found
that out oh I would have wanted to go I
should have told me you know kind of a
thing
so think about that right where me
that's kind of a lapse of judgment yeah
that's almost the same story that I just
said you know you we got an email I
didn't respond you met with the guy and
I was like and you're like dude I didn't
even think yeah that would be a big deal
yeah that's why it reminded me of it so
but it could be in a different dimension
whatever different scenario where yata
my younger brother could have been like
ah he excluded me on purpose yeah which
he didn't think obviously but and it
could also be him just like taking
advantage of the situation to make you
feel a little bit guilty you know what
I'm saying yeah I mean yeah yes you know
there's all kinds of Mind Games going on
in the world yeah yeah it could be one
of them
he wouldn't do that but it was like so
in you know the plan was to hang us all
three okay so what's your point in this
anyway my point is that's like a
legitimate lapse of judgment yeah versus
if that scenario was slightly different
if I did say hey I don't want let's not
hang with him let's go secretly hang
yeah do another hang you know well
that's why I intended so important even
you know when I said like oh you going
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground